I'm Charles Payne I'm Kat timpf I'm
Stuart Vonnie and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Friday November 4th 2022 I'm Chris
Foster the election day just around the
corner President Biden says democracy is
in danger our polling and pulling all
across the Spectrum shows that people
blame the White House and his president
directly for how they're doing
economically and they feel like they're
struggling so yeah I don't know that
that was their best closing message
we're speaking with Fox News Sunday host
Shannon Breen I'm Jessica Rosenthal
political divisions rank high on voters
lists of concerns in many recent Fox
News polls and while candidates on both
sides of the aisle highlight their
differences during elections other
candidates take a different approach a
more moderate one I'm running as an
independent so that I can build a
coalition of Republicans Democrats and
independents to replace Mike Lee and
stand up to our broken politics and I'm
Guy Benson I've got the final word on
the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
four days to go the midterm elections
are almost here President Biden says
vote like democracy depends on it now
extreme maggot Republicans aim to
question not only the legitimacy of past
elections
but elections being held now South
Carolina Senate Republican Lindsey
Graham on Fox responding to that speech
in D.C I thought it was pathetic I
thought it was divisive not one word
about how I'm going to secure a broken
border I'm going to lower gas prices as
president how I'm going to challenge
rampant crime how are going to make us
energy independent it was about half the
country uh basically being a political
terrorist he's hoping to be in the
majority when the new Congress starts in
January Democrats are trying to hold on
to the Senate it's considered a long
shot for them to hold the house Power
Rankings polls we have all this new
stuff it definitely seems like there's
this incremental shift to the
Republicans Shannon bream's the host of
Fox News Sunday do you know all summer
it's been a roller coaster Democrats had
the advantage on the Congressional
generic ballot they had an advantage in
a lot of these races as well and they're
so tight with so many things within the
margin of error I don't think anybody
should be celebrating on either side of
the aisle just yet looking at a couple
races here uh Republican Blake Mass
running for Senate in Arizona maybe a
little bit of a boost against incumbent
Mark Kelly the libertarian in the race
dropped out and endorsed Masters in a
close race that whatever two three four
percent could make a difference yeah I
mean he'll still be on the ballot but
the fact that he's out there actively
saying I tossed my votes I want my folks
to go to Masters is a big help I think
Carrie Lake and the gubernatorial race
everybody would have to agree has been a
big help for Masters as well our new
polling out of Arizona shows that
Republicans have the enthusiasm
Advantage there in these races and so if
they are fired up by Kerry Lake I think
that only benefits Blake Masters he has
definitely been trailing her versus how
she's doing in her gubernatorial race in
his Senatorial race so we'll see I mean
Arizona is one of those states that you
know they've had so much litigation over
2020 over how the votes went down over
people who want to be poll Watchers and
how that what's appropriate what's not a
lot of legal fighting and things going
on so I think we'll have a lot of
eyeballs on Arizona come election night
uh looking at Pennsylvania a lot of
eyeballs there the latest Fox News poll
has Democrat John fetterman up 47-43
against Meadows that's among voters
saying they've already voted or certain
to vote veterans down a point or so from
that with people who who haven't voted
yet so maybe the debate and criticism
over fetterman's debate performance
maybe it moved a little bit it may have
but as you noted I mean there's early
voting that's been going on all over the
place
um before debates debates not even
happening in some of these races so
voters are at a bit of a disadvantage
because they're polling there in
Pennsylvania also shows 51 percent of
majority of Voters say that the debate
performance with fetterman and Oz
actually factored into their vote will
that be enough to help us assuming that
you feel like okay fetterman I think
maybe doesn't get my vote because I
don't think he's far enough along in his
recovery or are there voters who say he
lines up with where I am on my
particular positions and I give him
credit for showing up
um in any case majority of Pennsylvania
voters tell us that debate actually
mattered to them so whether Oz can close
this Gap remains to be seen that was a
double digit lead for fetterman all
summer long and now yeah coming down to
the wire maybe that's a bit of an
argument in favor of people who say look
maybe maybe some early voting is fine
but not you know weeks and weeks before
voters have a chance to know all the
facts
and that that is definitely a
conversation that's ongoing is how far
in advance do we start this if we want
to make sure that we have voting
available for people who work different
jobs or are on you know work weekends
work weeks I mean you got to make sure
that there are equal and ample
opportunities for people to have access
it's one of our greatest rights and
treasures here in this country to be
able to vote but does that take six
eight weeks a lot of people would say no
and the question is too some of these
states start counting those ballots that
come in ahead of time I think we've
talked about this some of them do not
start counting those early ballots until
the day of so what happens is that night
whoever had the strongest vote tally
during the day is going to be in the
lead then there will be potentially in
some of these cases hundreds of
thousands of votes that still have to be
counted Pennsylvania Secretary of State
already warning it's going to take days
here don't expect anything that night
and you know that Riles up people who
feel like okay something's baked into
that post-election day counting but it's
actually just the way that the
Pennsylvania system is set up
um Shannon democr has been warning that
Social Security and Medicare are at risk
if Republicans take over Congress any
Merit to it
um is it a scare tactic I know that
there have there has been talk on the
Republican side of doing that
um Republican leader in the house Kevin
McCarthy was on Fox uh saying they want
to save and strengthen Social Security I
didn't I don't know about any specifics
but is it gonna is that going to be a
factor the fear of maybe older voters
saying or or people who want their
social security someday uh concerned
about it I do think that it resonates
with voters and you've heard it it's
been one of the talking points the last
couple of weeks on the campaign Trail
and from the White House for sure now
what the Democrats will point to is a
proposal that came out from Senator Rick
Scott which is immediately disavowed by
Senator McConnell and the Republican
leadership this was his idea this is not
something we're supporting we're not
going to cut entitlements
um on the house side when you press them
it's a little bit more difficult to get
details about what they mean they say
that yes there will be changes to the
program because it will be insolvent if
we don't make changes but what are those
changes does that mean Cuts now how does
that mean any trimming of benefits now
it's hard to pin them down on that but
they say absent some action by the House
GOP and Senate that those entitlement
programs won't survive anyway but yeah I
mean that definitely gives the White
House and Democrats the ability to point
to it and say your benefits may be in
danger and that definitely is something
that connects with voters and as we all
know the older voters tend to be the
more engaged and the ones that actually
show up on you know the election day or
leading up to it yeah I mean you can
change the funding formula somehow I
suppose you could incrementally up the
age the age of disability for um for
collecting Social Security and Medicare
I mean 65 isn't what it used to be there
are lots and lots of people who can
start collecting and then live another
few decades unlike in the past where I
was more you know generally at the end
of your life where you'd get those
benefits
um Barack Obama's been backing on the
campaign Trail uh doesn't seem to have
lost much off his fastball seems like
the same guy to me pretty much he is
fired up he does he seems like the you
know the guy who knew how to get out
there and spin a story Spin A Yarn
um channel the emotions and the passion
of the voters on his side no is that
just revving up the base they already
loved him and they already loved the
message that they're getting but can he
get those younger voters out can he help
bridge that enthusiasm Gap that
Democrats have in some of these key
races I mean he definitely has a ton of
passion and people listen and he gets
the crowd
um going with him so if that translates
into getting people more fired up to
turn out versus these people are going
to vote with you anyway but they were
just going to stay home it's a huge
benefit to have him out there on these
closing days I wonder if Barack Obama
being back out there is in some way days
a subconscious or not subconscious
reminder of who Joe Biden used to be
um he's obviously not the guy he was
when he was vice president and uh the
comparison between Obama now and Biden
now certainly isn't flattering uh
there's this George Will op-ed in the
Washington Post George Will big you know
for decades a sort of conservative
thought leader and he's begging Biden
and vice president Harris to drop out
and not run in 2024 and risk more more
Donald Trump he says that Biden frankly
is past the point not just past his
prime but past the point of adequacy and
he says that Harris is unqualified
yeah it's a pretty brutal piece
assessing the current Biden Harris team
from George Will's perspective and he
sort of ends up he's talking about you
know you know what one party's probably
gonna give you you know the illusion
there being Trump so don't give us this
rematch because it's just not going to
be good for the country he doesn't think
if it's a Biden Trump rematch and
there's so much speculation about this
about whether
um former president Trump is going to
announce his re-election in the next
couple of weeks depending on how well
Republicans do on Tuesday night and in
the when the dust settles from that
um but yeah I don't know the country
does not seem in polling very excited
about a Biden Trump rematch but man what
a moment in history that would be if
that's where we end up
um look if Democrats get their lunch
eaten on Tuesday you may hear Democrats
who are talking privately or quietly
about this Biden concern and maybe the
you know maybe that snowball
gets rolling a little faster and gets a
little a little bit bigger now President
Biden gave this speech about what he
calls threats to democracy apparently
something he felt he had to do after the
attack on Paul Pelosi and all the
election deniers potentially being
elected to congress uh he gave a speech
like this in September he talked about
it a lot he talked about this kind of
stuff when he was running in 2020
I don't know that it moves a needle for
any votes but it's something he felt he
had to do well I think for many reasons
I think um you know to obviously decry
what happened with papalosi but I think
he felt the need to do it because of the
election also I think this was kind of
that rally the base get folks out there
I was wondering as I watched the speech
who was the intended audience because I
think a lot of the people who their top
issue is worried being worried about
political threats in the January 6th you
know Fallout and the the tragedy of that
day I think the people who that's first
and foremost in their minds they're
already with President Biden they're
already going to vote with him but when
he talks about people he disagrees with
being the ones who could end democracy
in this country or put an end to this
country that's half the country that
didn't necessarily vote for him roughly
so I don't know if that message swings
Independence or brings over those extra
folks yeah um David Axelrod Democratic
strategist um he tweeted after the
speech essentially look it's a hugely
important issue in the moment and
appropriate for um the president to
address them but as a matter of
practical politics he writes I doubt
many Democrats and marginal races are
eager for him to be on TV tonight yeah
and they've been very careful as to
where they've deployed the president
um knowing that that there are listen
troubles with his approval numbers
um and policies and are polling and
pulling all across the Spectrum shows
that people blame the White House and
this President directly for how they're
doing economically and they feel like
they're struggling so yeah I don't know
that that was their best closing message
there was nothing hopeful about it there
was nothing about how here's how we lead
the country forward it was more
everything is over if you vote for
Republicans the end and listen I think
that we know fear will drive people to
polls negative advertisements drive
people to polls but at the end of the
day people have heard all of that I
think at this point a closing argument
may be on how you're going to turn
around the economy or the bright spots
that we've seen to show that maybe your
policies and your legislation are
working seems like maybe that would have
been a better use of the time
Shannon beam host of Fox News Sunday
always good to talk to you you too have
a great week
[Music]
this is Guy Benson with your Fox News
commentary coming up
during the primary season we heard a lot
about whom a former president Trump
supported and on the Democrat side who
was highlighting more Progressive causes
but then some candidates with more
moderate politics won their primaries
success as a moderate can depend on
geography how tight a district is but
some candidates say it's more than that
it's about looking at things based on
issues every single White House Press
Conference since I think last November
should have started about the economy
Michigan congresswoman Alyssa slotkin
who talked to this podcast last month
has long considered herself a moderate
Democrat the Republican former mayor of
Cranston Rhode Island Alan Fung may
become the first Republican to represent
the congressional district he's running
in in over 30 years I'm proud of that
fact that well there was my time as 12
years as mayor you know I had Democratic
councils Republican councils but no
matter what I put the party labels aside
did the right things for our residents
he told this podcast last month he
absolutely accepts the moderate label
and that may be the ticket to winning in
certain areas in Ohio a state that's
been trend ending red Democratic
Congressman Tim Ryan likes reminding
voters that he's happy to embrace
policies from either side of the aisle
as long as they put Ohio first we have a
lot of Republican support of people who
are coming over and helping us two-time
Trump voters a lot of veterans a lot of
people that just they like my message on
taking on China bringing back
manufacturing and I've got a record here
of bringing those you know Investments
here still very few run outside of a
party we currently do have two
independent Senators but they caucus
with the Democrats Utah Republican
senator Mike Lee told this podcast this
week his opponent may say he's an
independent and Utah voters may like an
independent-minded politician what they
don't like what they don't want is
someone who claims to be an independent
but is really a shadow Democrat embraced
by the Democratic party endorsed by the
Democratic party funded by the
Democratic party I don't regard him as
an independent but least Challenger
thinks Utah voters will regard him as
such I swore no to the Constitution when
I was a young CIA officer after 9 11 and
I still am committed to that oath to
defend and uphold the Constitution Evan
McMullen is a former CIA officer who ran
for president in 2016 against then
president Trump as an independent my
opponent Senator Lee took a similar oath
if not the same oath when he became a
senator and I believe he's betrayed that
though so when he tried to recruit
alternative electors to overturn the
will of the people in the last election
cycle it was a betrayal of the
Constitution and we simply cannot
tolerate that you know I'm I'm an
independent conservative who believes
that above all else we must conserve our
commitment to that founding document to
the Constitution and and that's one of
our main differences Senator Lee and me
the other thing I would say is that I am
committed to working across party lines
to solve problems now Washington has
broken our politics are broken Senator
Lee refuses to work across party lines
to get things done and we're suffering
as a result and I'm just not going to
take the same approach
you've said though that you you you're a
conservative your whole life but you are
running with that with that eye next to
your name the independent label so then
where do you feel your biggest I guess
Agreements are or disagreements are with
the current Republican party well I I
what I'm concerned about is just the
rise of extremes on both ends of the
political spectrum and I think they've
gained too much influence in both
parties frankly and I think they're
tearing our country apart most Americans
whether they're Republicans Or democrats
or conservatives or liberals you know
they have far more in common than they
do in difference and and we're led to
believe otherwise of course by leaders
who try to divide us but the reality is
most of us are common sense people we
want to do things that will keep our
country strong and maintain a strong
economy a strong National Defense you
know we want you know to have equal
opportunity most Americans can agree to
all of that and yet we're told that the
other side is is the enemy and so I've
got differences on both sides to the
political aisle but I'll tell you what
I'm most concerned with is ensuring that
our system of self-government our
Democratic Republic remains in a healthy
system in which people hold the power
not leaders not special interest groups
not party bosses but people that's why
I'm running as an independent I'm also
concerned with inflation and our
spending which is out of control both
parties are responsible for overspending
and adding to our 31 plus trillion
dollar national debt and we've got to
have people who are going to work
together to to get our fiscal house in
order and also I just think we've got to
be more serious about protecting our air
and water because at least here in Utah
we're really suffering as a result of
our failures to do that and I take that
very seriously yeah I think that water
fight around the Colorado River and all
the southwestern States is is only just
really beginning you told our own Brett
Bear on Special Report you wouldn't
caucus with the Democrats what have you
heard from utahns about this like I
imagine if they come up to you if they
bother to come up to you or engage with
you they're probably happy that you're
running as an independent but you hear
skepticism about sort of what your role
could be or would be in the Senate
without party to call my
well I'm running as an independent so
that I can build a coalition of
Republicans Democrats and independents
to replace Mike Lee and stand up to our
broken politics and you know last time
Senator Lee won re-election by over 40
points and and now many of the polls
have us within the margin of error and
so it's a tight race because we've been
able to build this Coalition and then
the question is yes you know how will
you operate in the Senate it's a senate
rule Senate Rule 25 that all Senators
have committee assignments and there has
never been anyone elected to the Senate
as an independent since at least World
War II every independent elected to the
chamber even the true Independents who
don't caucus with either side have
received committee assignments I know I
will receive them but the bigger issue
is this the Senate's very divided now it
will be very divided after this election
and the Senators who are willing to act
with greater Independence and to stand
up to party bosses on both sides have
the most influence in the in the the
chamber and I think they're the most
influential people frankly in Washington
second to the president I want that for
Utah we hear a lot about West Virginia
and how you know what does West Virginia
think but I think I think Utah has an
opportunity to help lead the country
forward and if we win it'll make Utah I
think one of the most influential states
in the Union
your opponent though says he's and you
know this he's accused you of basically
being a Democrat saying you've received
funding from Democrats the state
democratic party started support behind
you I imagine that it might be in part
because they don't feel they have
somebody else to throw their support
behind necessarily but what do you say
to those who do question you know where
you're getting maybe some funding or
where you're getting some support and
how that paints you
yeah well I'm raising money from
Republicans and Democrats and
independents and Libertarians and I'm
proud of that frankly I I'm proud of the
fact that we've been able to bring
people together Senator Lee uh says that
all my money comes from Democrats and
Democratic platforms it's just not true
we do raise money on both Republicans
and Democratic platforms because that's
where our donors are that's where our
supporters make their donations and I'm
proud of the fact that where we have the
support of people from different parties
and where else in American politics are
people coming together to keep America
strong and to solve problems and Senator
Lee wants everyone to believe that I'm a
Democrat because he knows that if I'm a
Democrat then he can win this race but
he's afraid of running against a true
independent conservative who actually is
committed to the Constitution but he's
just not I've been a lifelong
independent conservative and I'm still
that and will always be that and Senator
Lee is threatened by that and by our
Coalition of Republicans Democrats and
independents
I have a few more for you let's say you
get to the Senate we've heard we've
heard Republicans talk about curbing
spending and tying that curbing of
spending to the debt limit you know in
terms of maybe not raising the debt
limit anymore I know you've said as you
just did you do blame Democrats and the
Biden Administration in part for
spending contributing to inflation so
what do you do on that spending front
and what do you think of this talk of
the debt limit
well yeah I think the Biden
Administration deserves a lot of blame
for expanding the and growing the
national debt and also inflation I mean
the administration was warned by both
Republican and Democratic economists not
to move forward with the 1.9 trillion
dollar Aid package during the pandemic
and they ignored the experts and they
did it anyway and as a result of that
and other factors we've got sky-high
inflation but Republicans also sadly uh
added to the national debt during the
Trump presidency and and so this is
really not a partisan issue it's
something that we all have to come
together on as a country and and respond
to and frankly the only times in modern
history when we have gotten our spending
under control is when Republicans and
Democrats have worked together it just
it hasn't happened any other way I'm of
the opinion that you know we should not
default on our debt because I think it
would cause even more economic
instability and turmoil in our country
and so debating this at the time of of
managing the debt ceiling I think is not
the right time but I do think we have to
get more serious and I've articulated a
plan in ways that we can get our
spending under control but the time to
do it is not waiting until we have a
debt ceiling a limit it's about making a
serious effort to get our spending under
control long before that point
we many of us associate Utah with being
a more religious State
um and so I must ask you know we've
heard you say that you're pro-life what
does that mean to you as far as abortion
is concerned yeah I've always believed
in the sanctity of life and consider
myself pro-life I I am deeply concerned
about this issue and that it continues
to divide the nation but one thing we
agree on Even in our Coalition of
Republicans Democrats and independents
on this issue is that there is a more
constructive way forward most Americans
like me think the extremes on this issue
on both sides have it wrong you know
people who think there should be no
limits on abortions and then on the
other side people who think that there
shouldn't be any exceptions I I just
don't think that's right you know
forcing a 10 year old rape victim or any
rape victim to carry a pregnancy the
term isn't right allowing unlimited
abortions on demand in the late late
trimester you know is is wrong as well
but what we agree on is that if we make
contraception more available and do more
to support women children and families
and in part the right values to our
youth that is what will lower the
abortion rate in America and thankfully
most of us not the extremes maybe but
most of us can agree to that
one more if I may you know more of a
philosophical question maybe but you
know most people fancy themselves or
consider themselves
independent if you don't win
will you run for office again or will
you start try and start something new
based on being an independent
well I you know I haven't had much of an
opportunity to give what happens after
this race uh we've been very focused on
it I know you'd expect me to give that
answer you know I I don't know but what
I will say is that we have built
something new and important here in Utah
we've brought people together we've
found Common Ground we do it by focusing
on our founding ideals that we're
created free and equal and our deepest
purpose as the human is the pursuit of
of happiness and that's why we have a
system of self-government in which our
leaders are accountable to us not the
other way around we've built this this
amazing Coalition of utahns from across
the political Spectrum by focusing on
those founding ideals I think that in
order to strengthen America going
forward we're going to have to build
this Coalition all over the country and
so in one form or another whether
elected or not I will be a part of that
effort because if we continue to to be
as divided as we are we're going to come
apart as a country and I think we all
most of us feel that now it's happening
so let's find a way to work together to
solve problems and end this terrible
period of such great political division
and extremism Utah independent Senate
candidate Evan McMullen thank you so
much for your time
thank you
[Music]
listen to the all-new Brett Bear podcast
featuring Common Ground in-depth talks
with lawmakers from opposite sides of
the aisle along with all your bear
favorites like his All-Star panel and
much more available now at
foxnewspodcasts.com or wherever you get
your podcasts subscribe to this podcast
at foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for
your Fox News commentary Guy Benson
what's On Your Mind as I've thought
about the midterm elections this year
one of the big touchstones I've used is
whether or not this cycle would more
resemble 2018 but in Reverse where
Republicans would gain the house but
underperform in the senate or more like
2014 a big red wave that broke pretty
late in October of that year over the
summer the 2018 thesis was looking
pretty good with Democrats holding their
own in polling especially on the Senate
side and Republican momentum interrupted
but down the final stretch of this
campaign where voters really tune in and
undecided to start to break political
gravity is taking hold and 2022 is
starting to look a lot more like 2014.
Republicans should take nothing for
granted and the indicators could be
wrong but the race by race polling has
shifted toward the Republicans the
national polling has clearly moved in
the same direction and the so-called
fundamentals of this election have been
bad all along for the Democrats
historically the party opposite the
White House gains significant ground in
the first midterm election of a new
presidency couple that with an unpopular
president terrible right track wrong
track numbers and widespread economic
dissatisfaction on paper this was always
going to be a republican wave the
question has been would it be a ripple
or a tsunami we'll know soon enough and
anything can happen but as you examine
the factors that matter most it does
appear as though that Red Wave has been
building into something fierce and
voters will render their judgment very
soon I'm Guy Benson
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
hi everybody it's Brian Kilmeade I want
you to join me weekdays at 9am East as
we break down the biggest stories of the
day with some of the biggest newsmakers
and of course what you think listen live
or get the podcast now at
briankillmedshow.com